[MUSIC PLAYING]
I don't comment anything.
I do not leave comments.
I'm totally lazy about it.
And I'm sorry everyone
who has to read my code,
because it is completely
wild west, on your own,
figure it out from
the code, too bad.
I comment nothing.
The code is the comment.
Yeah.
Writing too many comments.
Too many comments?
Well, I could reduce
the verbosity.
I'm still trying to
learn, but because I
like to go back to
my code oftentimes I
feel like it's just like if
you come back to your code
a couple of months
later you'll probably
have no idea what you did.
But I like to kind of think
about that and mitigating
that problem in
the future and try
to write some comments
and documentation.
Sometimes the variable
names I use have no meaning,
they're just placeholders.
And that's OK, but it
helps when you're actually
deploying something or you
have something that you're
trying to share
with other people
to have something that has
meaning instead of just
a T or an X. I also am
really, really bad about going
back and cleaning up my code.
It's a bad habit
generally in research.
My worst programming
hack or habit
is to always take someone's
like a research code base
and start cleaning it up
and try to make it like--
remove all of the
boilerplate code
for like check pointing, like
parameter management and all
of those.
And basically plug-in all of my
own like open source packages
because it slows
me down initially.
But I think like it does
make like a clean code
base is important for
moving really quickly
and for like
communicating clearly
with their collaborators
and with the others working
with your code.
I really dislike when
stuff is not structured,
but when code is
not structured well.
But then obviously when
you're sort of just
starting on something there
is always that temptation to
or there's this trade
between spending
too much time structuring things
versus just getting it working.
And so I definitely have
found that pet peeve just
by doing it myself
and being frustrated
at myself looking back.
You know, why did I not sort
of organize this better?
And now I'm sort of
wasting time trying
to figure out what it was
I was doing a year ago.
Not going to sleep
when I should.
So problems seem to become
just like astronomically more
difficult as the day wears on.
And I think that
really the answer
is to go home at 5 o'clock or
6 o'clock and forget about it
and look at it again
the next morning.
But like all of us, I'm
a busy grad student.
I want to make progress.
Sometimes I get excited
about what I'm building
and so I'll stay up
super late working on it.
And I'll typically
find that those six
hours that I might spend in
the evening are terrible.
I introduce a ton of
bugs into my code.
I find like problems
just insurmountable.
And then I'll go to sleep and
be like, oh, nothing works.
And I'll wake up
the next morning
and fix it in 10 minutes.
So trying not to do that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]